is it safe to assume this will be your  final go-around thor yeah maybe i don't  know i'm so thankful to have done this  many and and so proud of this film and  it's been really interesting looking  back recently and thinking about my time  playing this character and how the  character evolved and also i was  evolving and learning and maturing and  so on and then even what eight nine  years later on the avengers infinity war  and endgame press tours that was really  the culmination of the whole universe  coming together and i think we all  realized and recognized at that point  that it's probably never going to be  done again it was never going to happen  to us again so that was really unique  and special and i have such beautiful  nostalgic memories about that moment